I like this
hey youtubers its charlie
welcome to my review of the Breaking Bad
finale isn't it awesome that I just
happened to have a green shirt lying
around
thank you very much he can sundry let's
do a quick recap of the episode and then
talk about our favorite moments and some
of our favorite moments from the series
and what it all meant to us so the
episode starts with while trying to
steal this car he's full-on paranoid now
and he basically is able to steal the
car and get to the Schwartz's those are
the people on TV that started great
matter with him we find out that he's
trying to give them money for them to
give to Walt Jr and his family did you
see that live free or die hard license
plate I thought that was so well timed
but Walt is amazing at turning into
full-on Eisenberg on a dime BAM he just
turns it on zap right in the back of the
head I love that the reveal of those two
hitmen that he ended up using ended up
being Badger and Jesse's other friend it
was just a little bit hilarious in this
moment that was otherwise super tense
badger best hitman west of the
Mississippi so walk goes to tie up all
the loose ends he learns that blue meth
is still being cooked so he goes and
meets with Todd and Lydia and we get
this amazing shot of this copy cup that
basically leads us to believe that he is
ricin poisoning Lydia after that scene
where Walt kind of walked up to the
table it led me to believe that he is
now the sneakiest human being on earth
seriously he could teach Deadpool tricks
he was in the Schwartz's house for like
ten minutes before they noticed he was
there and I have a feeling that this is
going to keep popping up through the
episode just Walt just slowly gliding
into frame without anyone noticing him
it's just beautiful
wouldn't it totally be hilarious if that
ricin shot was actually used as an anti
sweetener ad seriously a saccharine will
kill you yo so ninja Walt sneaks in
gives Skyler the lottery ticket with the
location to Hanks body and ties up some
of those loose ends and he says one last
goodbye to the rest of his family he
ends up making this really awesome DIY
gun turret but we don't find out what
it's for till later he travels to where
Todd and his uncle are keeping Jesse and
basically rescues Jesse but in the
process tries to get Jesse to kill him
Jesse refuses and Walt ends up taking
this one last tour through the meth lab
that he and Jesse designed that Todd has
been using and lets himself bleed out in
this really amazing cinematic moment so
since there were so many things that
happened in this episode and the series
that we could talk about I'm just going
to try and keep it
and we'll just add everything else in
the comments so there's something that I
don't mention or a moment that I don't
talk about just write it below in the
comments and we can talk about it there
but let's talk about our favorite
moments
what were your favorite moments from
this episode was it watching Walt tie up
all his loose ends was it watching Jesse
get revenge on Todd was it watching
wocket revenge on Lydia I feel like this
show does revenge really really well and
it really cinematic ways seriously
speaking of good cinema how well did you
enjoy the cinematic way in which they
shot this finale
I feel like breaking bad as a series is
kind of shot in this really amazing
cinematic way but obviously they just
poured it on for the finale just to make
it extra epic and the way they use music
to some of the song choices were just
amazing and do you feel like there's a
Breaking Bad sighs hole in all of your
hearts right now I know there's one in
mine let's try and fill it a little bit
honestly there were really two scenes
that were my top favorites one was the
ricin poisoning scene when the camera
panned down as she was pouring that
sweetener into her coffee that was just
amazing cuz it let you know that
basically Walt was walking around
cleaning up loose ends he wasn't there
for anything else other than to get
revenge on her and kind of find out what
was going on with Jesse and to was that
last tour through the meth lab it was
this really nostalgic tour that he was
taking through his and Jesse's baby and
I think it was really fitting that he
ended his moment there reader of Vince
Gilligan actually likened it to Gollum
with his precious at the end of Lord of
the Rings he's basically dying there you
know in the fires of Mount Doom it's
just like Walt with his baby there it's
his meth lab he understands the gravity
of what he's done with his life he's
made bad choices done wrong things but
he's just really really in love with the
thing that he created with Jesse his
real baby and what about the way that
Walt and Jesse kind of left their
relationship obviously as they got into
this episode they gotten to a point
where they basically become enemies and
Walter tried to kill him but Walt
basically had kind of turned this moral
corner and said hey I'm gonna rescue
Jesse just because he doesn't deserve to
be tied up like this so I think it was
really awesome that he made that leap
but I think was also even better that
Jesse would not kill him you remember
there was an episode earlier in the
season where Jesse was on a payphone he
said I'm never doing anything you ever
tell me
you again and he says it's basically
free from Walt's influence though I
think that Jesse is kind of trying to be
his own man now and they said that going
forward you know jesse is basically
trying to pick up the pieces of his life
but it's really hard to tell how things
are going to end for him but let me know
where you think all the rest of the
characters that are still alive at the
end of the episode are going after this
personally I think that Skyler will be
able to pick up the pieces of her life
obviously she doesn't know about the
money Walt didn't reveal that to her so
they'll get the money through Walt Jr I
think that'll end up happening so I
think that they'll eventually be able to
go on and be a family together they'll
be alright obviously they'll still have
the memory of this hanging over their
heads but I do think that they'll be
able to lead normal lives after this but
let me know what you think and like I
said right below in the comments if
there's anything I didn't talk about or
mention that you thought was really
important let's all Phil that Breaking
Bad sighs hole in our hearts this week
is actually a new episode of agents of
shield on Tuesday night I'll post that
video after the episode airs be sure to
subscribe to get it
in the meantime you can click here to
watch all my agents of shield videos I'm
doing one for each episode this season
it's gonna be a lot of fun and you can
click here to watch my other Breaking
Bad video thank you so much for watching
you guys are awesome high fives don't
high-five because it's over high five
because it happened